So we going to use this structural to higher our
pattern, to combine two data sets and these data sets
are going to come from forms and what we're
going to want to do, is understand what the reputation
or the karma of the author of a post is and to do this we're going to have to
combine two tables. A post table and a user
table. Sorry. And a post contains data about each post.
Some ID, the title of the post, any
tags this author ID, which is going to be interesting
and then the body of the post, and some
other things. The user table. This is the user
pointer ID. And that is the common key
we're going to use to combine these two data sets.
It also has some other information like reputation, which
is going to help us answer this question and
gold, silver and bronze badges. So, go ahead
and see if you can answer this question.